the first thing and this may be the most
important thing and the most overlooked
thing ever i have not used an alarm to
wake up in over a decade
so
you've got to remember your brain needs
a certain amount of sleep and if you
don't get that amount of sleep you can
actually test the cognitive decline so
step number one is really treating sleep
like one of the most important things
you're going to do you want to get to
bed early so that you don't have to be
pressured to set an alarm to make it to
work on time or whatever the case may be
so if you've got to go to bed at 8 00 pm
go to bed at 8 pm i know how terrifying
that sounds to you but i'm gonna have to
be honest if you're not prepared to
prioritize sleep then you're not
prepared to do the things you need to do
to be successful wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carmichael and this channel was created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven powerful
routines that will destroy your laziness
enjoy
routine number two take a walk with
brendan burchard people ask okay what
else do you do in the mornings i will
tend to take a walk in the morning if i
feel i need to do that and no matter
what i take two walks every single day
either morning or afternoon and then one
at night preferably after dinner to just
like settle myself down uh to to to just
like move my body around get outside in
the dark and just feel like that that
evening come on me so i'm ready for bed
routine number three
nourish your body with gabrielle
bernstein i have a glass of hot water
with lemon i have sometimes a green
smoothie sometimes i'll have a cereal
i'll have like a rice brown rice cereal
and i'll eat before i caffeinate and
this is this sounds like a sort of
trivial thing but it actually is a very
important part of my morning ritual
eating before i caffeinate is so crucial
because
whether i'm having green tea or a cup of
coffee by the way i am back on coffee
that's that's been about a year now back
on um i just couldn't i couldn't i
couldn't live without it and so coming
coming to that caffeine after eating is
so crucial particularly trying to eat
some fats in the morning i'll take
sometimes a scoop of coconut oil or i'll
have you know
some protein of some kind but really
trying to give my body some nourishment
before i caffeinate because
anyone knows if you caffeinate on an
empty stomach you're just gonna spike
your adrenals your stress levels your
cortisol levels we will be raised and
you begin your day with this frantic
energy and then very quickly you'll tank
and i am a fan of sustainable energy um
i've become recently a big fan of the
bulletproof coffee so if you drink
coffee maybe consider putting a lot of
coconut milk or they put butter in the
coffee eye i dairy free so i put in
coconut oil
and putting some kind of fat in the in
the caffeine to just really
allow it to take you on that sustainable
energy rather than spiking your stress
levels
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there routine number four do what
matters with lewis howes this morning i
got up early i breathed into some
meditation i made my bed and i did a
hard workout and now i came here to the
studio to talk about this and for me i
feel confident i feel like man i've
accomplished so much before
10 am right i've already done so all the
things that i care about i've done and i
feel more confident so this is what's
this is what's powerful this is what's
available for you is gaining if you feel
like you're not a competent person if
you feel like
you doubt yourself if you feel like
you're unsure of yourself or you're
insecure
spend time for an hour and a half in the
morning doing some of these things and
trying them doing things that are
uncomfortable for you you're gonna build
confidence in the first hour and it'll
go into the rest of your day so i'm far
more confident in my skills and
abilities as a creator as a partner
as a friend
and as a leader because i know
i put in the things that i care about
first thing routine number five think
and strategize with patrick bay david i
wake up generally at 4 30 4 45 when i
have training sessions at 5. if i have a
training session with my trainers at 6
i'm up 5 15. this morning i had a
training session at 6 00
i can no longer help myself it's a 4 45
wake up i'll have 4 45 i'll wake up i'll
check my email i'll go through all the
information that i have on my email
i'll typically listen to an audio book
while i'm driving or walking around
i will do my daily affirmations on what
i tell myself it's been one of my
rituals for a long long time i have my
affirmations laminated all over the wall
it'll be all over my shower wall
everywhere
uh on what i tell myself
then then i go to the gym i do my
routine i do my workout in the morning
weights
right after that one of the things that
i've been doing recently that i love let
me tell you this is a very
fascinating thing if you have the luxury
of doing this i'm 6'5 240. so my back
and my knees feel it a lot especially
when i was in the army we used to rock
march with 50 found 50 pound backpacks
that's what we used to do right
so creole therapy paul why don't we put
the video up so they can see what it
looks like creole therapy
is something i've started doing recently
uh you literally stand there with no
shirt on no clothes on and you stand
there this thing starts and it goes all
the way down to -240
and the system i use there's many
different ones these machines are around
a hundred thousand dollars it goes to
minus 240 for three minutes
by the time you're done what happens to
the blood the entire body
flexible it feels like a million bucks
and your body gets shocked is what it
does now i do this at six o'clock in the
morning
so it works very very effectively if you
can't do that at your gym it's great
even if you do it once a week i highly
recommend it for you to try creo therapy
good breakfast you gotta have breakfast
because that's your gas tank so remember
if you go and do 10 miles 20 miles 100
miles 200 miles in your car you need to
go to a gas station breakfast meals are
your gas stations you need to go fill up
the tank then i do my thinking these are
the times that i do my thinking i do my
strategy sessions i do my ideation i
think about what i'm working on my next
project
uh what needs help what needs to be
improved what needs to who who do i need
to call who am i what are my
conversations going to sound like what
am i going to do with this what am i
going to do with that so it's thinking a
lot of thinking and strategy
and praying definitely praying and
meditating catching up on news uh if if
my kids wake up early they'll typically
wake up at 6 45ish i'm typically gone by
then
but i'll play with them when i get home
and so that's typically what my days
look like in the morning rule number six
adopt the two-minute rule with james
clear i encourage people to build a
habit that takes two minutes or less to
do so you take whatever you're trying to
do read 30 books a year becomes read one
page or
do yoga four days a week because take
out my yoga mat
and sometimes when i mention that idea
people resist a little bit because
they're like okay buddy you know i know
the real goal isn't just to take my yoga
mat out i know i'm actually trying to do
the workout so if this is some kind of
mental trick then like why would i fall
for it basically
well
i tell the story of of this guy mitch
that you mentioned this guy who i met i
talked about him in atomic habits he
went to the gym he's lost over 100
pounds kept it off for more than a
decade
and when he first started going to the
gym
he wouldn't stay for five longer than
five minutes he had this little rule he
had to leave after five minutes so he
get in the car drive to the gym get out
do half an exercise get back in the car
drive home
and it sounds ridiculous right it sounds
silly like obviously he's not going to
get the guy the results that he wants
but if you take a step back you realize
that he was mastering the art of showing
up right he was becoming the type of
person that went to the gym four days a
week even if it was only for five
minutes
and this gets us to that deeper truth
about habits that you just mentioned
this idea that a habit must be
established before it can be improved it
has to become the standard in your life
before you can optimize it and scale it
up into something more
and you know i don't know why we do this
like we get very all or nothing about
our habits we're like we're so focused
on finding the perfect business idea or
the best workout program or the ideal
diet plan
that we spend all our time theorizing
and researching and looking for a better
way
and
instead if we could just master the art
of showing up even if in the beginning
it was less than what you had hoped to
do
you're establishing a foothold you're
building some small progress that you
can advance off of
and it reminds me of ed lattimore has
that great quote where he says the
heaviest weight at the gym is the front
door
and man there are a lot of things in
life that are like that you know like
the the hardest part is getting started
the hardest part is establishing the
routine even if it's a lower level
baseline than what you ultimately hope
to achieve
but the reality is if you can't become
the type of person who masters the art
of showing up even if it's just for five
minutes then it doesn't matter how good
the plan is it doesn't matter how great
your theory is and so
i think the two-minute rule pushes back
on that perfectionist tendency a little
bit and just encourages you to master
the art of showing up and routine number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is plan your day the
night before with brian tracy few hours
of the day are more important than the
early morning hours
one of the great thinkers said the first
hour is the rudder of the day it sets
the tone for everything else that
happens
these hours when you first wake up set
the tone for the rest of the day
affecting your mindset and productivity
during all the hours that follow them
plan your day the night before
planning out your day the night before
may not exactly be part of your morning
routine but it is a great way to get
your day started off right
in fact i was just reading the story of
a very successful self-made
multi-millionaire multi-business
developer who said every single morning
he starts off by reading his goals every
morning he never misses a single day
by planning out what you want to
accomplish the night before you can
start off each day with a plan in mind
rather than waking up unsure what it is
you want to tackle first
plan out your morning routine as well as
to what you want to do when that routine
is complete then wake up the next
morning and put that plant into action
your brain does not want you to hit your
dreams your brain
is designed to keep you small to keep
you safe to keep you protected your
heart wants to create amazing things
your heart has big dreams your heart
sees a beautiful world and says i want
to go make something better and then you
wake up the next day
and your brain takes over and says you
can't do that
that's too risky
that's too dangerous stay small stay
safe you didn't go to school for that
and what ends up happening is this
constant back and forth between your
heart and your brain when you're getting
these motivated moments when you want to
do amazing things and then your brain
takes over again and keeps you small and
this is the path that so many
entrepreneurs go on this roller coaster
ride up up and down and up and down and
up and down and up and down
sound familiar
it's time to get off the roller coaster
and start making progress on your dreams
today's video i'm going to show you how
so
yesterday i got asked on my live stream
evan what's the most important part of
your daily routine
and so many people have so many
different daily routines and and it's
easy to do the things like drink a glass
of water in the morning go outside and
get some sunlight and you know all of
these things but the most important
thing for me is actually having my
intention for the day i've actually been
experimenting with writing it out the
day before so this is this is what i
wrote last night
of basically my entire schedule
and then more than just what i'm gonna
do more than just what i'm gonna do it's
how i wanna feel what's my intention
going into it so if i look at this i'm
supposed to be recording espresso videos
right now right that was on my list 10
30 a.m record and espresso videos it's
right there and here get a head start
even though you don't want to
recording videos at the beginning is
always difficult for me there's a couple
reasons why i'm
i'm shy i'm introverted i don't crave
the spotlight i don't like being in
front of the camera
i don't i don't i don't do it for ego
purposes
and also i'm afraid i'm afraid
because i want it to be great i want
this video to be the next best video i i
don't want to disappoint people my
number one fear is gonna be that i'll
disappoint somebody and so every time
you make something you risk
disappointing somebody
where it's easier just to stay small
stay safe don't make anything today and
so it's on my list the to do right i
think a lot of you if you're watching
this video you probably have a list of
to-do's but how many of you are actually
doing the things on your list of to-do's
the hardest part often just getting
started
already as i started recording this
video it's a lot easier to keep going
and recording more videos this is the
first one that i'm recording today
and so having that written down
get a head start even though you don't
want to
reminds me of who i want to be
and what i find so valuable about this
is i write this the night before
so the night before you know it's it's
11 o'clock at night i usually sit on the
floor and i review my calendar for the
next day and i write out what i'm going
to be doing and i've added how do i want
to feel what's my reminder to myself
before stepping into that task imagine
you're being your own high performance
coach sitting there telling yourself how
you want to feel remember your intention
before starting that next task
and i knew
okay this is what you always do before
you make a video there's a little bit of
procrastination there's a little bit of
fear there's a little bit of slowness
there's a little bit of
not laziness but there's a little bit of
just apprehension before you get started
why because you don't want to start
because you're afraid because you don't
want to you don't want to disappoint
people so i write down that message
again get a head start even though you
don't want to why do i focus on
gratitude first thing in the morning
well i have my vision board and then my
goals everything that i want but i also
have a gratitude board the things that
i'm most grateful for in my life and if
you want to feel instant gratitude just
count all the things in your life that
you have that money can't buy gratitude
is also good for your brain there is a
cover story on the cover of time
magazine on these super nuns who are
living 80 90
and above and they want to find how
where's their longevity coming from half
of it had to do with their gratitude
emotional faith the other half had to do
with there were lifelong learners so
those two things combined and very very
powerful
after that i'm drinking my tea i'm
writing in my journal because a lot of
geniuses write in journals right
leonardo da vinci einstein marie curie
all these journals and they want to do
these studies say are geniuses writing
in journals because they're geniuses or
is it the opposite it's because they're
writing in journals that they become
these incredible geniuses of their field
here's how most people though
unfortunately start their day they wake
up from bed and they reach over they
grab their phone and they pull their
phone to their face and then they go
and they start scrolling through and
some people you can literally hear them
growing you know what i mean it's like
they just immediately start the day
their real morning routine is starting
their day in social media now let's talk
about why that is bad scientifically so
not my opinion not like i'm the guy
telling you stop doing instagram i'm
sharing with you some results from the
world's largest study that's ever been
done on high performers high performers
are basically the top 15
of the most successful group in whatever
their category is meaning it's the most
successful 15
of business owners or the most
successful yoga instructors or the most
successful videographers the most
successful whatever we've studied over
two million data points from 190
countries around the world to understand
what do high performers do what are
their habits what do they do what do
they focus on what's their mind like not
just like how do they show up but rather
what are they doing willfully and on
purpose and one thing they are not doing
is starting their day in social media
almost none of them but think about what
that will is it's like you wake up you
grab the phone uh you start scrolling
through psychologically what is that
doing for you
first social media is triggering in your
mind the comparison frame
you immediately start comparing oh look
at her abs oh look at his thing oh he's
got this look at their followers i don't
have that impact i wish i could be like
this i want to be like that you're
immediately comparing your life to other
people what else you're doing you're
scrolling and as you're scrolling
neurologically we know that as doing the
reason you like to scroll so much and
swipe so much and move so much through
that phone is because every time you do
it fires off in your brain something
called novelty and when we have
novelties something new to look at our
brain likes it and our brain says well
let's give him a little dopamine a
little vasopressin let's make him feel
good and so oh the more i do this the
more your brain goes distraction yay
look new things shiny sunshine and
you're swiping through this and as you
are swiping through all of this
you are forgetting your life and your
day i mean imagine would you ever tell
like a middle school kid hey what i want
you to do uh kid is wake up every
morning and immediately start thinking
about how the other kids in school are
and start comparing yourself to
everybody
no none of us as adults would teach
small children to start their day
comparing themselves to other people
and yet that's what you're doing when
you pick up that phone
what you're doing is you are
neurologically training your brain
to be rewarded by comparison and
distraction because right think about
the anchor here wake up grab
look scroll and what is that doing it is
training your brain
first thing in the morning
check out of your life and check into
other people's lives
every morning you are training your
brain to check into other people's lives
not
carefully and strategically and
intentionally think about yours
so what that means is if you're a person
who is checking your phone first thing
in the morning going through social
media
you by definition
by checking into other people's lives
comparisons yourself to other people's
lives you are ultimately training your
brain neurologically to live
other people's lives
to see life from the perspective of
other people's versus your own vision
your own dream your own thoughts your
own strategy your own intention
you are training your brain to live
other people's lives
so that's the worst thing you can do
please be thoughtful about this and i
know i know when you're like but it's
hard brendan i just love to pick up the
phone i know i know because that's an
addiction
every time you do something if you have
to do it every day and it's something
that you do every day that is leading to
a negative result that's an addiction
and you must teach yourself to break
that you must not do that i had to
personally i literally do not have my
phone by my bedside
like when i had this i noticed i was
like gosh i check in
i've seen the results i've seen the
studies why am i doing this so i turn my
phone off i put it in the kitchen
counter charging and i'm in the bedroom
sleeping which is really important right
to keep you sane so i think it's just a
change the worst morning routine we can
have is to immediately be in the day in
comparison and distraction
second terrible routine that people love
to do is they gotta check in again check
in
email i gotta check my email i gotta
check my email i gotta check my text i
gotta check this but listen your texts
and your email
are nothing but convenient organizing
systems of other people's agendas
think about that for a minute what shows
up in your inbox or in your texts what
shows up in your messages
other people's will for you
other people tell you what to do what to
think what they need from you what the
deadline is stress stress stress stress
stress
and most people
are literally beginning their day
checking their text their voice message
and their inbox which is all other
people's agendas and needs from you
so again you are starting your day in
other people's lives and needs
your mom probably told you growing up as
well as to make your bed and there is a
great
book
by william h mcraven that says
it's about making your bed and he is a
navy admiral that talks about
if you want to live a great life
make your bed and this is a massive
number one your time best-selling book
this speech went viral online
and it's something that is so simple
but sometimes we think about we've got
to have some complicated morning routine
that
you know biohacking everything we can in
order to optimize our day and really
when we go back to the basics
that's when you start to transform your
life everything goes back to basics
so make your bed first thing there is
there's something that happens and i
started doing this years ago there's
something that happens
when you
decide to take pride
in your personal space
when you decide to say okay i slept here
i slept here for
uh you know six seven eight hours and i
wanna make sure i have a clean space
when i come home at night
by doing that you set yourself up for
success you accomplish something first
thing in the morning you build momentum
and you create pride and confidence in
yourself because you did something for
you
you did it for yourself so when you come
home at night you can say wow the time
and energy i spent early in the day paid
off for me tonight now i can go to sleep
in a restful space so something to
consider try this for a week make your
bed every morning it it's the last thing
you want to do because you want to get
up you want to go to the bathroom you
want to brush your teeth and you want to
get on with it but i'm telling you if
you take those two three minutes you
come back at night you'll be proud of
yourself
for what your past self did to help you
in the future my whole life is really
about teaching people exceptionalism and
one of the real strategies for high
performance and leading without a title
is getting up early you might say
getting up early is not really relevant
to you and yet if i look at the best of
the best whether it's in business and
science in the arts in sports
these are people who have trained their
brains
to show up at discipline
and getting up early is not only an
incredible competitive advantage because
most of your competitors are asleep but
getting up early is a great gift to give
yourself you get more life
ben franklin said it really well he said
there'll be plenty of time to sleep when
you're dead
so getting up early and giving yourself
that 60 minute personal leadership hour
really you practice and you prepare just
like beckham practices to be world-class
as a footballer or
hamilton lewis practices on the track to
be a world-class car racer or mozart
practice to be a world-class
composer
you give yourself one hour from five to
six and you do your practice but here's
the thing i really want to focus on how
do you get up earlier
so a few quick
hopefully very practical ideas number
one get super fit
when you are in world class physical
condition you just need less sleep your
metabolic rate is higher you have a lot
more energy a lot more stamina a lot
more passion get super fit and you're
just going to need less sleep number two
every single week get a massage getting
a massage
is not a waste of time it's
not a cost it's an investment why
because it'll increase your circulation
it'll help you get by on a lot less
sleep it's something that every peak
performer should do every seven days
just to
allow yourself to play at your absolute
best number three your diet eat less
food you'll have more energy don't eat
after eight o'clock and
eat every four hours a little bit of
protein a little bit of carbs but the
real key is eat less food manage your
diet you will need less sleep another
idea
get up in the morning and take the time
to write in a journal in other words
dump the worries out of your mind onto a
crisp white piece of paper when you
worry you lose energy i call it
dissipation and the more things you
worry about
the less energy you will have and the
more sleep you'll need and the fifth
thing i'll say is learn to find ways to
love your job
lead without a title i have met
room cleaners whose
clean hotel rooms like picasso painted
so find ways in your current job
to be passionate about your job be the
absolute best in your job why because
few things create more energy than going
to work every day and feeling that your
work is meaningful feeling that you can
show leadership within your area of
responsibility feeling that your work is
a craft whether you flip hamburgers or
work in human resources but one of the
great secrets to passion is purpose in
your work get up early it'll be one of
the best moves you make i wake up at 6
15 to this alarm clock that simulates
the sunrise then i pet my dog then i
always make my bed uh this is a really
important tip so the night before you uh
are going to sleep lay out your exercise
clothes because when you see them in the
morning it acts like a trigger in your
mind to remind you of your promised
exercise and even though i get dressed i
don't feel like exercising here's
another pro tip
i
program my mind to be positive
all day and i practice gratitude while
brushing my teeth i brush with my
non-dominant hand which is the hand that
you normally don't write with so i brush
my teeth with my left hand because i'm a
righty and then as i am brushing my
teeth with my left hand i have to pay
attention
uh because it's not really a natural
thing to do and as i'm paying attention
i have my gratitude practice where i
think about what i'm grateful for i love
it when the spring flowers are coming up
we've turned our family room into a gym
and
i have uh tagged a bunch of the classes
and instructors that i love for you to
check out oh gotta go to the bathroom oh
there's chris uh now let's get started
with the class braxton here we go oh
forgot my water bottle i have terrible
add it is true what do i put in my water
bottle baraka holly jacobs from sony
pictures television i love you for
introducing me to this
kind of hard to exercise when you have a
puppy
but makes you grateful
uh what do i eat for breakfast either a
smoothie or eggs from the chickens
across the street and i'm telling you
right now
your morning routine is everything so
get up early and find time for yourself
so there you have it that's my typical
morning routine and
it never fails every morning that i
stick to my routine i have a
much more powerful day and the mornings
that i don't stick to the routine
suck honestly because i wake up behind
the ball when i get up when the alarm
rings i have made and kept a promise to
myself
when i make the bed i am
uh completing something before i leave
the bedroom and i also
whenever i walk back into the bedroom i
see something that has been accomplished
i don't see a mess that needs to be
completed
um by prioritizing my
physical and mental health
and getting some exercise in i not only
feel better mentally but i also release
chemicals in my brain that helps me
focus there is no doubt that having a
powerful morning routine is part of
every successful person's programs it is
something that you deserve it is
something that you should create for
yourself and it is something that will
improve your life refresh your routine
why is this important i'll tell you why
that's this is important because there
is so much science that talks about the
power of your morning routine and
there's also so much noise out there
about the morning routine and i don't
know about you but when i read all these
articles about the power of a morning
routine i'm typically reading them by
some male influencer who clearly doesn't
have children yet or some male ceo no no
offense to the dudes but all of the
articles out there tend to be written by
guys that have
two and a half hours before work starts
to somehow drink mushroom tea and
meditate and go to yoga and exercise and
drink bulletproof coffee and sit in an
infrared sauna and i don't know what
planet these people live on but they
clearly don't have children or a job
they need to get to at eight o'clock in
the morning and not to make anyone wrong
i'm being realistic i'm being realistic
about the fact that you need a morning
routine but you need one that works for
you
and for where you are in your life in
this season you see i had a morning
routine that used to take me 30 to 40
minutes
last year when i had more time i've had
a morning routine that took an hour when
i had time and the ability to go for a
jog in the morning i'd incorporate that
in the morning routine do you realize
that my morning routine right now
has been responsible for helping me curb
my anxiety it's responsible for why i'm
so successful and i'm able to be
productive my morning routine 10 minutes
long that's it it's 10 minutes long
because that's what works for me in this
season of my life here's the thing about
morning routines i think morning routine
envy is a real thing
and
i do believe that a lot of people lie
about their morning routines
i think lying about your morning routine
is a real thing i think pretending you
have the perfect morning routine
is a real thing
um
i'm
i'm about when i'm home i'm almost 80
in my morning routine i get it done
because it's super simple right so i
mean i think i need a simple one yes
and when i'm traveling
i almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses i think
the key to having a morning routine and
morning routines are critical
because how you start your day
has a
massive
proven impact on how your day turns out
there's one piece of research that i
think is really profound and this comes
from sean anchor i talked about this
yesterday but i'm gonna i'm gonna tell
you um this too susie
if you consume three minutes just three
minutes of negative news
of negative television
of negative emails maybe stressful
emails from work or stressful texts from
friends
you have more than a 50 percent chance
eight hours later to say you had a bad
day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind
it literally sets your mind up to be on
the lookout for things going wrong
and so the reason why a morning routine
is is actually so important is because
number one
it determines what your priority for the
day is
and we also know based on research that
your mood in the morning it impacts your
productivity all day long you must come
up with a morning routine
that you do
every single morning or at least more
mornings than not
that puts you in control of yourself
and in control of your day
this is what i do
and i cannot explain the power that i
get
from starting my day off and being
bigger than my excuses and being in
control
first and foremost
wake up on time when that alarm goes off
get your butt out of bed five four three
two one go
why is that important for persistence
the reason why is because the first
decision that you're making of the day
is to actually get up and get moving
that means you are
persistently
bigger than your excuses
you are persistently bigger than feeling
lazy and you are persistently beating
the feelings that typically stop you
the second thing that i want you to do
before you look at your email
before you answer your phone before you
start surfing vox and vice and buzzfeed
and you know team stream and checking
out the sales on zappos and looking at
your facebook news feed before you pick
up the damn phone
please please please
figure out your two priorities for the
day
these are the things that matter to you
whether it's saving money and and making
sure you're focused on that or showing
up at work and being a contributor or
whether it's changing how you treat your
spouse or your kids or the person that
you're with or heck getting to the gym
because you said you would whatever it
is that your two priorities are
put them in your head before you pick up
the phone why
the reason why
is because of persistence the reason why
is because i want you to have a good day
do you know what makes for a bad day
what makes for a bad day
is
snoozing
starting your day off late starting your
day off tired starting your day off by
mainlining everybody else's news feed on
social media and looking at everybody
else's life and and saying to yourself
oh my god they're on vacation or gosh
they look so great or their friends are
so fancy or my gosh they've got so
you start off your day looking at that
you're never gonna have a good day you
gotta start off your day by getting up
on time figuring out your priorities and
then getting to work on them do not pick
up your phone until you have done those
two things i think the single biggest
reason why people have bad days is
because they start them off by looking
around at everybody else and seeing what
they're doing instead of having the
focus and the discipline
to actually start your day off with you
in control and with your priorities
front and center so you want a bonus
round exercise every day that's right
get up on time figure out your
priorities and exercise you do those
three things you'll be kicking
every single day they work out
i work out
what
this is a big one there is a ton of
science that proves that exercise really
optimizes your brain your mood and your
ability to focus hence optimizing your
ability to get things done now if you
haven't read this book you have to get
it right now it's the best book on the
subject it's called spark by dr john
rady and we'll put the links right below
this video so whenever i'm coaching
someone that has a hard time focusing
one of the first questions i ask them is
are you working out and 99.9 of the time
the answer is no so in my own personal
experience i always strive for 60
minutes but at minimum 30 minutes a day
of just sweating my buns off and i'll
challenge you to do the same thing
because i know when i get that done it
really helps my brain focus and i know
it'll help you too now one of my
favorite things that i do now
is that i have this little post-it note
that i keep next to my bedside table
and on it it says
what are you grateful for and that
message starts my day with a different
thought studies have shown that when
you're present in gratitude you can't be
anywhere else
so when you're having a grateful thought
you can't have an anxious thought when
you're having a grateful thought you
can't have a negative thought and so
it's so powerful to start your day so
grab a post-it grab a sharpie and write
a question on it that you want to answer
first thing in the morning
now you'll be able to tell that i like
post-its because as i brush my teeth i
have this post-it and i got into the
habit of this when i lived as a monk
where i put it in front of me
and on it it says i am awareness this is
one of my favorite affirmations to start
the day with i recommend this to clients
to people i'm working with because when
you start with that mindset
you disassociate and disconnect
with the thought of i am the body or i
am my mind and if you think about it we
always say my mind and my body and
spiritual teaching suggests that we are
actually awareness consciousness and so
that reminder at the beginning of the
day
sets me up to now look at my life as an
observer to look at interactions as an
observer to approach relationships
physiologically
one important aspect of you
is your heart
the pumping station
for your blood circulation which pumps
life
across the
body this one thing doesn't happen
nothing happens this starts from left
side
so we told you you know in india they
have told you when you wake up you must
roll to your right side and get up have
the
left side if you roll and get up bad
things will happen to you did they tell
you bad things are not about that
when you are in a certain state of
relaxation
when the body is in a relaxation the
metabolic activity is low when you get
up there is a certain surge of activity
that's why they told you in india
all these things are built into your
life which you're throwing away the
whole signs of living has been built
into your life they told you in the
morning before you wake up you must rub
your hands together and see like this
huh
not see like this you must place it upon
your eyes
you do this
you will see god
it's not about seeing god
if you rub these two things together all
the nerve endings there's a heavy
concentration of nerve endings in your
hands
if you do this the system comes awake
immediately
you're feeling asleep you're feeling
sleepy just do this and see
everything comes awake
so morning before you move your body
you get it awake first
and then place it upon your ass
instantly a whole range of
nerves
connected with your eyes and the other
aspect of your senses come awake
before you move your body
your body and your brain should be
active you shouldn't get up dumb that's
idea
[Music]
understand so you do that and then roll
over to your right and get up
each one of you watching this video
opened two very special gifts this
morning
guess what
your eyes
i often say
last night was the last night for some
and we are blessed with another chance
to live a better life
and we can make the most out of our day
and thus out of our life if we begin our
day in a proper state of mind
here are the five things to dwell upon
as soon as you are up every single day
number one
begin your day with gratitude
don't just charge your phones
watches tablets or laptops the first
thing in the morning
charge yourself up as well with
positivity that will last you all day
and the most powerful of all positive
emotions that'll make you feel empowered
is gratitude
because it forces you to shift your
attention to your blessings than to your
problems which are anyways going to be
an integral part of all of our lives
second
resolve to have a positive vision
nobody including ourselves is perfect
everybody has a good
and a not so good side to them and the
tendency of the mind
is to look at the not so good side
every morning
resolve that you'll try and look at the
positive side of people and neglect or
deal with the dark side
because the more we focus on the
negative our mind becomes occupied with
others faults ruining our work our day
our peace our joy and even our
relationships
third
trust the broader plan
tell yourself that whatever is going to
happen today the apparent good
or the apparent bad
is exactly what i need at this point of
time in my life
nothing more
nothing less
have complete trust
that every incident that's going to
happen throughout the day
that which is beyond your control
is simply a small part of a much
larger picture that will unfold
eventually only for your good and your
well-being
keep reminding yourself of this as
you're confronted with challenging
situations through the day
number four
do the small things right
although folding your sheets or
converters may seem small they lead to a
very big attitude like the us navy
admiral william mcraven said
making your bed in the morning will
reinforce the fact that little things in
life
matter
if you can't do the little things right
you will never be able to do the big
things right and by chance you have a
miserable day you'll come back home to a
bed which you made
and a maid bed gives you encouragement
that tomorrow will be better
and number five
decide to help someone
don't they say
everyone you meet is fighting a battle
that you know nothing about
be kind be helpful
invest the energy of empathy love and
kindness and people around you and
you'll receive the same back when you
need it the most
also try to have a spiritual practice in
your morning routine
a deeper connection which will
illuminate your inside
so you can brighten the outside one
thing that i
that's actually a pr like a really
practical thing that i did
that and that is i had
uh this is again this is just like a
real practical thing i had
two cots
right slept in a cot slept in one cot
something one caught the other cot was
all my gear
and it was just laid out gun body armor
you know everything was right there
and when i
when i got dressed to go out
all that thing was empty
and so
never forgot anything
when i came back everything went right
back on the cop same spot same spot
everything squared away
so those that to me was and i figured
that out really quickly okay just gonna
i don't ever want to forget anything
here's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna put
everything that i need right here what
are the three things we should say when
we wake up in the morning or think
well first i would say
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that i can be today
and i would not get up until i felt like
that person
the second thing i would say is can i
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if i do it properly then i will
be open to opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing i would say is could i
sustain brain and heart coherence to the
point where that intelligence within me
that's giving me life begins to find a
door to open out so i can begin to see
evidence in my world move because when
you move in the morning and you sweat
you'll release bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor
which will optimize your cognition it
will make you think more effectively as
you go through your day
did you know bdnf actually helps you
promote neurogenesis which is actually
the creation of new brain cells bdnf
through sweaty exercise will also help
you repair brain cells that have been
damaged through stress powerful because
the quality of your brain sets up the
quality of your performance
sweaty exercise in that first 20 minute
pocket of move of the 20 20 20 formula
will also release dopamine which is the
inspirational neurotransmitter which
gives you fire in the belly as you go
through your day universe
university of toronto did some research
and found that the effects of a morning
exercise actually lasts 19 hours after
your workout
cortisol the fear hormone is high in the
morning exercise will reduce it
exercise in the morning will release
serotonin which is the pleasure neuro
chemical which makes you feel happy
through the day now it's 5 20 you're
feeling fundamentally different go to
bed with the intention of pure awareness
and settling into
infinite formless
identity
and i cultivate that awareness in sleep
i've been doing that for decades now
and so i have a
uh witnessing awareness experience even
in deep sleep or dreams
and there's a recognition that i'm not
the body mind
then when i wake up
you know before i get into the identity
of deepak chopra which takes a little
bit of time
i just have the same
awareness between
waking and sleeping and then between the
sleep state and the waking state is that
little gap of pure awareness
and i enjoy that
and then i start my meditation process
and
it's all while i'm still in bed i
i'll obviously sit up to do that
and then i go have a wash or whatever i
have to do and then i do yoga i do yoga
seven days a week
when i'm traveling i still do my yoga
every day seven days a week in my room
and i always get a yoga mat from the
hotel we make our bed we start our day
with excellence how you do anything is
how you do everything now keep in mind
one of the big questions we got was
where do you get all the time right to
do all this and i'll show you that i'll
go at the end how long each thing takes
but i'll give you an idea when i make
them in bed how long is may take to make
your bed very very little but i do this
with excellence and then you take
excellence throughout your day i'm
remembering my dreams takes just two
minutes to go through um the next thing
here making the bed only takes one or
two minutes uh drinking water that
doesn't take any extra time if anything
is just you're always you're already
doing it three minutes exercise it adds
things absolutely because the big thing
is where do i get time because my goal
is for not this not to take time is to
help you to make time and focus and
energy and productivity and more
exercise three minutes brushing my teeth
should take the same amount of time
that's interesting cold showers if
anything it's less time tease smoothies
on occasion sometimes i do intermittent
fast and you might have heard episodes
of that i've done uh with past experts
journaling
here's what i do i take three minutes to
journal and what i'm like journaling in
the morning i'm writing down three
things i want to achieve personally and
three things professionally now the
biggest way to save um
time on this is it's not just what
you're doing it's also what you're not
doing notice the thing i
said i i didn't say i did which is touch
my phone and i know this is
controversial i understand some of us
have to check our phones because our
life depends on it our career depends on
it again
take these guiding principles and apply
it for you you can design your days you
can make your life about what you want
it to be about so what do you want it to
be about what should you
majority of your days be about for you
in terms of creating contributing and
connecting but they what should they
also be about for you your character
who's going to show up on your ideal day
what would you be like on your ideal day
would you be weak and fearful or would
you be courageous and strong would you
be judgmental and mean and upset full of
hatred and
jealousy and anger and regret about life
and other people or would you be
somebody who's open and excited for
other people and connected with other
people and positive and enthusiastic
what would you be like on your ideal day
have you ever written that down here's
who i would be on my ideal day
here's how i treat my wife my partner my
spouse my lover the kids here's how i
treat strangers here's how i treat other
people and then the idea is don't wait
until the end of your life
to have that ideal day
don't wait until next year or next week
to have that type of day we can choose
to wake up every single day and live
that day in an idealistic way for
ourselves in a way in which we show up
as who we want to be in a way in which
we are doing things that enliven us and
engage us in it and get us excited in a
way that we're doing things and being
with people and creating experiences
that feel alive and fulfilling we can
have that type of life i call it the
charged life and everybody can have it
it's a matter of discipline in getting
it and here's one simple trick and tool
to make sure you get more of those ideal
days when you start your day you must
own your morning
you must own your morning look if you
thought about your ideal day i bet you
didn't say well i roll out of bed i grab
my iphone and i check my email right
that's not an ideal day you have to own
that morning to make sure that you're
proactive with that data say you know
what okay what is i want to be about
this day what are the things i want to
achieve and create and experience this
day what kind of character do i want to
cultivate today what do i want to learn
today give today grow today you have to
have some aim and intention to have a
phenomenal day and it's not that you
can't go with the flow and the bumps and
the bruises and the struggles and
hardships of life but when you're
experiencing those you can still
experience them from a place of presence
and peace and enthusiasm
even the ultimate challenges in my life
and i've faced i've lost friends i've
lost my father to leukemia i've been
through my own multiple brain injuries
car accidents atv accidents broken
enough bones in my body it's kind of a
sad story really but every single
hardship i've ever faced including
leaving and starting my own business
even
moving to new cities every major
challenge obstacle in my life i always
chose
to meet that as my ideal self i always
say well how my highest self interact
with the situation i'm making the bed
even though we're checking out of the
hotel this morning
because every single morning i have the
same simple morning routine cat
i get up on the alarm rings i get moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal do a brain dump i
make my bed
and even though we're checking out of
the hotel
um it's so important
to keep to your routine because the key
to changing your life
is change your daily habits
the way that you start to change the big
things is you change the small things
make tiny teeny teeny promises to
yourself and then keep them so i have a
promise to wake up and get up for myself
for years and years and years i would
get up to make the school bus i would
get up for school i would get up because
my mom was telling me to i would get up
because i had to get to work i would get
up to get my kids to school
today i get out of bed with the alarm
rings for myself
i make the bed
as a gift to myself
now normally when i'm home
the gift is i get to come back to a
nicely made bed
and i have a beautiful place to lay down
and dream
it's also a gift because i start my day
by completing something
but it's also a gift
even though i'm checking out of this
hotel this morning because
i am
building the foundation for all change
which is consistency
so
here's how you put this into practice
think about what you want your morning
routine to be come up with just one
promise you're going to make yourself is
it going to be to get up in the alarm
rings is it going to be to make your bed
let's start with making your bed
tomorrow morning you're going to wake up
and you're going to make a promise that
you're going to make your bed for
yourself do it every morning and you are
building the habit of consistency
and that habit of consistency is the
backbone to all change every weekday i
wake up at 6 00 am i haven't set an
alarm for a long time but i know that my
body will naturally wake me up based on
the routine that i've created
i usually sleep for about eight hours a
night and i'm very grateful to have that
much time and i prioritize sleeping at
about 10 pm every single day
when i'm up the first thing my mind
wants to do is say something like i feel
so tired i've got so much to do today
and i as soon as i wake up in that
moment rewiring reprogram it to say i am
happy i am healthy and i am healing that
simple internal affirmation and
statement rewires how i feel about what
i have that day i'm grateful for the
opportunities in the work i have i'm
healing with the challenges i have and
my body is healthy because i'm able to
get out of bed i don't look at my phone
in the morning trust me i don't always
follow this i've broken that rule many
many times i'm not perfect i've failed
at it countless times but i keep trying
to rise back to this rule why because i
feel amazing the amount of clarity in my
mind the stillness that i experience
when my phone isn't the first thing that
i see
is
inconceivable and i highly recommend
that you try it out just for seven days
don't look at your phone first thing in
the morning and see how different you
feel for the rest of the day i promise
you you're going to feel more energetic
more productive and more creative than
you've ever been before now i've been
practicing something for a long time now
called mindful brushing i brush each
tooth for around four seconds before i
move the toothbrush this mindful process
allows me to start the day at my own
time in my own pace so often before i
used to rush brushing my teeth
not only would i be damaging my gums and
damaging my teeth by the way dentists
will tell you about that i actually was
starting my day off in a panic with
stress
slowing down the first activity of the
day
allows you to start and move at your own
pace in your own time most people are
literally beginning their day checking
their text their voice message and their
inbox which is all other people's
agendas and needs from you
so again you are starting your day in
other people's lives and needs
and think about that and how powerful
that is especially for people like me
and maybe you like i consider myself a
people pleaser
like i want to do good for other people
i love to lead and caretake of other
people i love to be that person who
supports other people and some people
they give their whole life to other
people without ever having shaped their
own life
all they do is do what the husband says
do what the wife says do what the family
says do the parent says all they do is
do what that inbox says do what those
text requests are all day
what are they doing
they're reacting
to other people's needs drives ambitions
so your whole life you're marching under
somebody else's flag you're you're
following without even knowing you're
building in the capacity to be a
follower
and i'm just here to say i listen i'm
not saying you shouldn't ever check
email i'm not saying don't check your
text or voice message notice what i'm
saying don't do it first thing in the
morning
when you check into your inbox you are
checking out of your life
when you immediately react to other
people you are taking yourself out of
strategy and thinking about the day i
mean for one second think about this
again go back to that middle school kid
hey kid wake up in the morning and
immediately i'd love for you to start
using your mind to compare yourself to
other people to be distracted and only
think about doing what everyone else
tells you what to do
will that child ever grow up with
freedom autonomy joy the significance of
building a life that is theirs versus
reacting to everybody but again if
you're waking up and that's the first
thing you're doing that is an addiction
that's leading to a negative result and
for those who are like yeah brendan's
just yapping at me
the world's largest study of high
performers show
if you check your email in the first 60
minutes of the day you decrease your
weekly productivity
by 30 percent
take that one home
if you check your email within the first
60 minutes of waking you are decreasing
your productivity
by 30
in the week
people say brandon i would love to get
more productivity everyone says well i
don't have enough time no you're just
using your time really bad in the
morning
to create these frames where you're
comparison so you're getting discouraged
to create distraction so you're training
yourself to be distracted throughout the
day instead of focus throughout the day
you're checking into everybody else's
needs so you think about doing
everything for everybody else and not
thinking about your dreams your wants
your desires your ambitions your goals
your contributions and i'm here to tell
you you have to be very careful
getting 30
of your productivity back though that's
so hopeful
that's so hopeful and of course people
go well brendan that sounds like
pseudoscience well here let me share
with you results why is it you're able
to get more done each week
is because instead of doing those things
you're going to begin your day
intentionally
instead of checking in the inbox before
you even open the inbox sit back and say
okay what are the primary activities i
need to do today
to move the needle towards my dreams
what are the primary actions
activities projects tasks that i must do
today to move it forward for me for my
dreams for what i want to create in the
world
who do i need to reach out to to ask for
help or to delegate to or to ask this
for like instead of you using the inbox
as a tool
to consume and do what everyone else
does use as a tool to communicate say
okay if i'm gonna open that inbox the
first thing i'm gonna do is reach out to
people hey i'm waiting on this i need
this from you could you send that to me
okay great like do that before you
respond anything if anything that we get
more productive
also please think about this please
think about this
what if as you thought about the major
things you have to do
that you just blocked some time during
the day to ensure those things happened
so for me as an example
i never do email
before the major creative things i need
to do during the day like i'm filming
this video right now i've done zero
email today none because like this is
the major thing that makes a
contribution this matters more than
email
you've got to re-prioritize your life to
doing the things that matter if you're
in my book high performance habits
you've learned about this concept called
pqo
it stands for prolific
quality output
the difference between the most
successful people in the world and
average performers
is that they focus most of their time
during the week on average it was 60 for
them
on doing the things that mattered the
most
to create the outputs that advance their
life so for example an output that
advanced my life is video an output that
advanced my life is online courses is
the business work right that advances
what i'm doing here and i have to look
one of the big boulders that move your
life forward versus focusing on picking
up all the scraps and the pebbles which
is where all the scraps and pebbles live
in your social media or inbox
i'm here to tell you but also warn you
and lovingly cajole you
use your morning to think about your day
we live in a world where people don't
reflect anymore a lot of people are busy
being busy but what's the point of being
busy around the wrong things
so for 20 minutes from 5 20 to 5 40 you
reflect you pray or write in a journal
meditate you can visualize you can
script out a blueprint for a great day
ahead which habit researchers call a
pre-commitment strategy which actually
increases your willpower and your
ability to get your most important
priorities done
the first thing i do i sit on the edge
of the bed i thank god i'm alive i just
like waking up
and i'm i never say
speak negative so
man i hope i hope it's a good day today
no
i say today is gonna be a great day i
claim it
i lay claim to it that's the first thing
the second thing uh
at least 20 minutes
sometimes it lasts an hour it depends
i have a journal
i have a daily devotional called jesus
calling
and i have a new living testament bible
i sit down i just ask god to show me
what i should learn today
and he flips i open the book to whatever
he wants me to read
and i read it i highlight it i take
notes about what i learned
i study it
and i try to put it into action
and that's every day
now a lot of people say steve i don't
have time to do that you do have time
if you don't have time you should make
time
because
gratitude
is the number one way to become
successful
because the more grateful you become the
more things god will give you to be
grateful for
that's a very important question
so if you start your day with gratitude
it's like this like check this out if
you if somebody come to your house every
day
and ask you for a cup of sugar
and you give them a cup of sugar and
they take the sugar and they just walk
off
and then the next day they come and they
ask for another cup of sugar
and you're a nice person so you give
them another cup of sugar and they just
walk off
how many days can this person
come to your house and get this cup of
sugar and never say thank you
how many how many times you gonna let
that go down
seriously
survey said you know how many days
not many because you're human because at
one point you're gonna say hey wait hold
up man you didn't came by here six times
i didn't gave you this cup of sugar and
you ain't saying thank you one time
don't come by here no more
so now let's think for a second
if this god wakes you up every day
allows you to breathe see it's not your
alarm clock that wakes you up
your alarm clock goes off god shakes you
then you hear the alarm clock it's not
you that's waking up
it's god allowing you to wake up
so if you ever stop to just thank him
for everything he's done for you
whatever clothes you got whatever kind
of car if you just got taxi fare and you
thank him every day for a list of things
guess what he'll do tomorrow
he will add to that list of stuff that
you can thank him for and if you keep
thinking you'll find out that in one
week
you have a lot more stuff to be grateful
for gratitude is the number one
principle of success that's what the
average person doesn't understand you
can do that today i think the number one
thing i did to give myself permission to
stand in my greatness was i got in the
mirror i got in the mirror and i did an
exercise that's three sentences and i
invite you to do that today
when you get in the mirror
finish each sentence with seven
different endings the first and always
say your name first so i would say lisa
say your name first i'm proud that you
seven different things that you can
celebrate yourself for
and then the second sentence say your
name first i say lisa i forgive you for
seven different things that you can
forgive yourself for begin to cut the
shackles to blame shame guilt and regret
and anger from the past and then the
third sentence is lisa i commit to you
that make seven new commitments to
yourself i did that every day every day
right after i brush my teeth
i would rinse the toothpaste out and i
jump right into making this declaration
to myself i'm proud that you i forgive
you for and i commit to you that that
way i began to fill my own tank up so no
one else had to do it and as i'm serving
others i'm serving them from my overflow
not from a depleted tank that's key
one beneficial habit that you can
practice every morning is to get up and
read 30 to 60 minutes in something
uplifting and inspirational each day
when you get up in the morning and
instead of reading the newspaper or
watching television you read something
positive and constructive and inspiring
you set your mental stage or tone for
the rest of the day
throughout the day from the first day
that you try this you will notice that
things go better for you you'll be
calmer you're more productive you're
more creative you're more alert
you'll actually be more resilient and
will respond more effectively when you
face the inevitable ups and downs of
your daily life
just like vigorous physical exercise in
the morning will prepare you to be more
resilient physically during the day
positive mental exercise in the form of
inspirational reading will prepare you
to be more mentally fit
during the day
people are always asking me in seminars
bob how do you schedule your day
and you know that's not an easy answer
for me because every day is different
with me i do a lot of different things
but there is one constant
it's how you start your day earl
nightingale taught me that a long long
time ago he said bob it's not how you
spend your days it's how you start your
day you start your day off right and
everything is going to work in your
favor and you put seven of them together
and you've got a very successful week
so he said pick a good idea well you
know i have a book here um how to sell
yourself to others by elmer wheeler
elmer wheeler was one of america's
greatest sales people so i use that and
i just open it here
what we call manners that's an idea what
we call manners
if i win manually all day long if i keep
that in mind i want to be mannerly with
everybody all day long
that's going to help me so i take an
idea like that every morning and i write
it down i put in a piece of paper carry
my pocket and that's an idea i'm going
to work on all day long if something
goes a little wrong i work on that idea
i take that idea you do this and you're
going to win
i get asked about morning routines a lot
i've interviewed hundreds and hundreds
of top performers in various fields
about their morning routines and
where should you start this is one of
the most common questions and i'd
recommend starting off very very simply
number one when you go to bed put your
phone on airplane mode because if you
wake up and your barrage with text
messages and notifications and so on
you'll be immediately short-circuited
you want to have a boot-up sequence of
your own and i do believe as i've been
told if you win the morning you win the
day so what are a few ingredients if
you're starting as a blank slate i would
recommend number one waking up making
your bed i know this sounds odd it was
first recommended to me by an indian
monk he convinced me of the merits
because you are accomplishing
one thing at the beginning of the day no
matter what happens with unforeseen
variables for the rest of the day you
will return to a maid bed at the end of
the day and as a bookmark beginning and
end it sets you up psychologically to be
more productive and also to feel better
even if things go sideways later
in addition to that if you work at home
in particular
it's common that external mess
creates internal mess in terms of mental
state
so making your bed does not mean four
seasons it just means in my case
pulling up the sheets and blanket and so
on so it looks like
i haven't had an elephant rolling around
in my bed that's really quite simple and
then arrange the pillows in a semi
pretty fashion subjectively and there
you have it
what i recommend for many people right
after that is just do
10 15 push-ups or some type of sun
salutations or something like that to
primary nervous system
and that's effectively from tony robbins
or many ways to do this cold plunge and
so on called shower but to get your body
physiologically into a state
where you can then sit down and have a
more optimistic story for setting
strategies and so on for the day if
you're in a depressed state you're going
to see problems instead of solutions and
ultimately have a really tough time i
think starting your day
on the right note and in the right gear
in addition to that if you want to add
extra credit i would suggest that you
consider either journaling which i do
almost every morning with most typically
the five minute journal which you can
look up with my name you'll find plenty
of details i don't have any business
stake in it or morning pages which are
recommended to me by an exceptionally
successful screenwriter
for
using
putting words on paper as spiritual
windshield wipers in effect trapping
your monkey mind on paper so you can get
on with your day
those are two different complementary
approaches that you can explore and
experiment with
when i coach the superstars i notice
they all have a trade in common they
have massive levels of what i call
curiosity iq they understand that the
person who learns the most produces at
best okay so greatness belongs to the
learners and fortune favors the curious
read an autobiography
or you read a book on productivity or
you look at your game charts on
your targets or you listen to a podcast
or you watch a video course but you give
yourself that learning because as you
know more you can do better
in many ways the people who create
empires the people who change history
are people who are incredible students
you know you never want to lose a white
belt mentality because nothing fails
like success i see it with so many
companies i work with members of the
fortune 100 i see it with professional
athletes you know they have a
championship season and they start
resting on their laurels and they you
know stop learning they stop mentoring
they stop pushing themselves to the
limit but one thing the a players and
virtuosos all have in common they
understand that last year's championship
season
is this year's starting point here's how
i want you to think through your day
from now on first and foremost i want
you to list you know the one two
three
maybe four or five
projects that you have in your life
right now and i want you to list just
what are
three simple things you could do or
three three things you need to do to
advance those projects now these do not
have to be necessarily your daily to
do's these are the things that you have
to be on your radar of things you must
accomplish to advance the major projects
of your life forward let me give you an
example if one of my projects is
write and publish new book okay if
that's it
one of the things i have to do is you
know as part of moving that forward is
right book
two
find agent
three create promotion plan like those
are big picture things i need to do i
might not necessarily do them just today
we'll get to that but those are things i
need to have on my radar to remember
that these are the big projects i'm
working on and these are the major
components of moving those forward by
starting strategically each day and
thinking about the major projects we're
working on and how we're moving forward
in life
again assuming you've studied our
previous videos where we talked about
having a purpose right and thinking
about what's my mission today then when
we get to the project level it's it's
just keeping on the burners it's helping
us understand what it you know what are
the things i've got to make sure i'm
working on and paying attention to
the second thing i want you to focus on
is the people in your life and of two
categories i want you to brainstorm
every single morning i print this out
and i work through this
next this people category i want you to
think through two things
i want to
think of categories of people as one
the waiting on category
and two
the reach out to category
and here's what i mean by that
i want you to sit and think about every
morning
who am i waiting on a decision for
or information from
for me to move forward in any of my
projects or ultimately what my
priorities would be in other words if
you just sat and you brainstormed every
morning who am i waiting on
what information do i need from whom
who owes me some data who owes me
something that i've been waiting for and
until i get these things i cannot move
forward i want you just brains from that
without opening the computer right we're
not in your computer yet say it again we
are not in your computer yet okay i
already think about what is
who are you waiting from and i just want
you to write down i might be like oh
from tom i'm waiting on this proposal um
from so and so i'm waiting on this email
from this person i'm waiting on the
decision about the event coming up and
i'll just brainstorm that often i can
find very easily 10 to 20 people i'm
waiting for something from
then again do not open the inbox
then i want to think about who do i need
to reach out to today to advance my
projects why need to reach out to an
agent well i need to reach out to
someone who knows about book promotions
well i need to reach out for some and so
who knows about this event i need to
reach out from this person who i need to
learn from this person from that i want
you to think about who do you need to
reach out today that would advance the
projects of your life
and brainstorm all those people okay
i'll talk again how you're going to work
through these
next is your priorities
i want you to
list
five to ten things that you must do
today that's why it's a priority these
are must be done
know it do it accomplish it today not
five days from now again these projects
some of these things you might be able
to knock off today but some of them
might be big picture things you don't
get to priorities these are my skit twos
morning which is a time
i try there are days at least thrice a
week i try and like get to get in like
quick workout you know you have those
abs now so i'll say okay today is my
eight minute workout and i'll do some
eight minute like something or abs or
whatever and then i'll forget the next
day so i'm never consistent with it but
the one thing that i try and do mostly
is skip
i love skipping i learned it really
really well in school and then i learned
it even better during mericom so i try
and get my cardio in by skipping it's
easy to carry you have your skipping
rope in your bag it's easy to do so what
is neurobics well neurobics means doing
something new i tell everyone the mind
is brutal it has a use it
or lose it and when you use your mind
constantly
you find new neurons all the time which
is why professors of 85 have almost the
same brain capacity of someone of 35 but
we have this excuse oh i'm too old now
it's normal to forget things it's my age
when actually little tiny kids forget
things go to a school and you'll see
every day on the peg someone's forgotten
their coat their lunch their swimming
stuff
but we start to think well yeah i'm
tired i'm forgetful
it's my age it's not your age it's
because you are not using neurobics if
you look at a child they color they get
up they can do something else they come
back they're always doing something new
and new means use it or
lose it you have to train
your brain to stay young and active and
sharp and there are many people of 95
with super sharp minds and other people
of 60
who are letting their mind kind of
wither away and
if you put all your work into having a
great fit
young looking body
but you're forgetful there's no point in
that if i could choose how to age i
would choose to mentally age really
really well because then i could say
well i'm 95 and i'm alert and i'm wide
awake i wasn't having a great body when
i can't remember anything or focus or
concentrate
but you can have it all you can have a
fit body
and a fit mind if you use neurobics and
here's the great thing about neurobics
you don't have to go to the gym
no membership is required no hour of
doing press-ups and lifting heavy
weights and doing lunges is required and
it doesn't hurt you go oh my stomach
aches now and it's really hard work
doing all these chest raises
it takes five minutes it's free it's
easy so let me show you
what neurobics is it means new
but it also means the wrong hand most
people are right-handed if you're
left-handed you're going to have to
reverse this if you're
right-handed like me what you need to do
is clean your teeth with the other hand
it feels kind of weird but that doesn't
matter and even better when you clean
your teeth with the other hand
balance on one leg for a minute
for 30 seconds but do something with the
other hand when you reach for your phone
use the other hand notice how much you
use this predominant hand for most of us
it's our right hand we use our right
hand to reach for things to comb our
hair to pick up our phone
train yourself to use the other hand
every day reach for something
with the other hand and know that every
time you do that you are making yourself
younger and here's something amazing
wherever you start from in your house
you will always if you're right-handed
start up the stairs using your right leg
wherever you start from it's quite fun
to try you will always go up the stairs
first on this right leg make yourself
lead from the left get to the stairs and
put your left foot on the stair first
because you are firing new neurons the
mind loves newness it needs newness
so do some new things clean your teeth
with the wrong hand and balance on one
leg just for a minute when you clean
your teeth
reach
for your phone
your paper your cup your spoon with the
wrong hand use the wrong hand
start going up the stairs using the
wrong leg the unfamiliar leg and finally
and this is really easy
if you do a crossword puzzle every day
because these things are really good for
your brain crossword puzzles suduko
mind games anything new if you're
learning something new like a new
language
doing anything that's different is great
for your mind now that the blinds are
opening we can actually see something so
i keep my clothes right there next to my
bed
keep headphones right next to my bed
that way i am ready to rock and roll as
soon as i get out first thing i do is
put my headphones on
uh i start listening to a book or a
youtube video
then i would come in i would brush my
teeth
again i did all of this earlier because
i didn't want to wake up lisa
but just by way of recreation that's it
so i would come in brush my teeth then i
snatch up the dogs
feed them
then as of right now anyway it would be
off to the gym key part of any morning
routine is the order in which you do
things so
for me depending on what's going on in
my life i may prioritize the gym or i
may prioritize meditation but one of
those two things is almost always going
to come first it's going to be pretty
rare that i don't do that now as the
time that we're recording this we're
going into the summer so right now i'm
really prioritizing the gym also coming
off of the quarantine where i was maybe
a little bit more relaxed hyper focused
on the business
the gym was something that came a little
bit later in the day the problem is
depending on what your priorities are
and mine is definitely marriage first
then business then physique
that if something crazy is going on in
the business and you know i'm trying to
get things done there then whatever i
haven't done first thing in the morning
it's possible that it just doesn't
happen so um right now because i'm
really focused on the gym even though my
ultimate priority list hasn't changed
the reason i'm recording this now is
because as you guys know i wake up so
early that there was nobody to film me
doing this stuff but the way that i
think about the gym right now it's the
first thing i do so i wake up i put my
gym clothes on i immediately bee line
to the kitchen if i'm completely honest
i feed the dogs and then i
will drink a bit of water and then i
head straight to the gym
i do a pretty simple workout routine i
do a push pull legs and abs so
push meaning i'm doing chest and
actually i do it in a different order i
do pull
then i do push then i do legs and abs
then i repeat the cycle my nine-minute
routine as soon as i open my eyes as i
try to think of and we all know this i'm
gonna say something that you've never
heard before try to be grateful but
here's what i've done i've lowered the
bar of gratitude everybody in this room
has accomplished so much that sometimes
we set the bar so high with gratitude we
don't realize it like we're look we're
searching for gratitude like how did
every something spectacular happen how
did the moon the stars part or the the
clouds part and i saw like no like wake
up and realize 150 000 people die every
day
today 150 000 tomorrow yesterday
you woke up
sometimes i wake up and go wow these
sheets feel amazing
god this is a comfy pillow like just
find something and all you do is just
trick in your brain to be grateful in
the moment not a big long gratitude
process and i'd love i love to meditate
i've been meditating more than i ever
had i'm just talking about your first
thoughts and if you if you have troubles
with that then grab a book that you love
you know there's a couple habits books
out that are really awesome right now
there's just like
high performance habits millionaire
success habits there's some great habits
books i'm just saying
no but grab a book that you love or the
bible whatever fills your soul and just
read three sentences just so your mind
is opening up the moment you open up
you're filling it with gratitude you're
filling it with appreciation
filling it with personal growth right so
the way i look at it is i protect myself
offensively by leaving my phone on
airplane mode don't check it yet
i do a couple minutes of either
low-level gratitude or i'll literally i
love the untethered soul i love a lot
you know i love a lot of books but the
untethered told for me i could open up
any page read two sentences and get
something from it right so i'll either
read that and then soon as i do that i
just immediately think of some intention
for the day now guys this is literally
all in minutes i'll think what do i want
to accomplish today what would make me
feel good uh today literally this
morning i woke up i said today i want to
live the experience with this crowd i
don't want to go up and try to remember
what to say i just want to be present i
want to serve what is the most important
thing you practice daily in order to
achieve your goals your daily goals and
get you to success transcendental
meditation is obviously the most
important thing to do day in and day out
transcending is the key
to a better and better life
and this idea is catching on more and
more in the world
the receptivity to transcendental
meditation is growing by leaps and
bounds
thanks to so many in this room and so
many else others around the world it's
really happening it's built for the
human being
and transcending our nervous system is
built to transcend and experience that
unbounded eternal
infinite immortal immutable ocean of
pure consciousness within
it's money in the bank
meditate regularly and then the second
thing i do is drink coffee creating
daily success routines is the secret to
getting everything that you want
everything that you want out of life out
of business your hopes your dreams your
ambitions everything that you want lie
on the other side of what you are doing
daily of your daily success habits and
routines i think we let ourselves down
by default i think we worry about other
people's opinions by default i think we
play small every day by default i think
you should have already accomplished a
lot of the things that are on your list
but you're stuck in procrastination mode
because you are playing small by default
because you are not consistent because
you do not have the habits on a daily
basis to keep going consistency
consistency consistency is the
difference maker chart your start what
you do in the first 15 minutes of your
day matters chart your start have a plan
of action most people wake up like an
accident most people wake up they're
tired you pull out your phone you start
looking on your email and what are you
doing when you're looking at your email
or looking at social media you're
responding to other people's emergencies
you wake up you're tired and the first
thing you do is you start responding to
other people's emergencies i want you to
control the first part of your day chart
your start understand what it is that
makes you come alive understand what is
the action that helps you feel bold
creative unstoppable we've all had it
you've all had moments where you felt
bold courageous and unstoppable what led
to that reverse engineer yourself what
led to you feeling bold is it watching a
video is it reading a book is it having
a conversation is it doing a meditation
is it taking your dog out for a walk is
it cutting the grass like i don't care
there's no judgment i don't care what
the thing is that makes you feel bold
and courageous and unstoppable i just
want you to do it daily i want you to
start your day with intention most
people don't start their day with
intention and that makes the difference
between the people who achieve success
and the ones who don't and so chart your
start figure out the thing that makes
you come alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible and put that into the first 15
minutes of every day
if you did the thing that made you feel
bold courageous and unstoppable in the
first 15 minutes of waking up every
single day
not every day will be amazing but i
guarantee you that your life will look
unrecognizable from where you are right
now
chart your start so when i wake up in
the morning
the first thing i do is i do a gratitude
exercise where i ask myself usually in
bed
what am i most grateful for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful
for to be alive i'm grateful you know
for my family i'm grateful to to have
experiences and do you do that eyes
closed yeah i do that eyes closed and
while i
while i think about that i feel it
and so the feeling starts every day with
a great feeling
i start every day with a great feeling
you have do you visualize some things
like your children or do you talk to
yourself how do you do that yeah i have
an internal dialogue um i see images of
the things that i'm thinking about and
that just takes me two minutes just two
minutes when i wake up
and then
i go to exercise to take care of my body
how long um usually one hour to an hour
and 15 minutes every day
and so i do
a variety of different things i hike i
bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise
in my gym what around
half an hour an hour 15 minutes at the
moment so then in my gym i have uh two
things i have a vision board which is my
dream board for my you know you are
known for that yes so i have my vision
board for my my physique and my body and
my health
but then i also have in in my gym
something called an achieved board
okay so after i achieved some of the
things that i achieved best and future
no achieved in the past yes so past you
have the past and the future
so
i have in my in my gym in my home gym i
have a
like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus to
achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals but what i
also do is i reinforce most people focus
on what's not working this isn't going
well this didn't work i want to remind
myself every day
of look how many things i was able to
accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals so before i go into
my meditation which is with my eyes
closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally associated with it to remind
myself that when i set my mind to
achieve something
i can do it
and then i look across because i have a
mirror
in the gym and i look across and i say i
love you just the way you are and i said
i accept you just the way you are with
all of your skills and passion and
faults and insecurities and doubts and
fears i accept you just the way you are
and i smile
and then i close my eyes
and i do about a 15-minute meditation
wow
and
in my meditations sometimes i have
no thoughts where i'm just one with the
universe and everything
other times i'll just follow my thoughts
and i'll just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one
and follow another thought and say
release that one so i'm teaching my
brain
that i'm in control of my brain what
i've said before is that regularity is
critical going to bed at the same time
waking up at the same time and certainly
using alarms can help you do that and i
use the word plural there alarms what i
mean is not to have multiple awakenings
in the morning i mean we should all set
a to bed alarm you know think about the
time that you need to go to bed to get
that eight-hour sleep opportunity and
then set the alarm maybe sort of 15
minutes before and that's just the call
it's sort of like last orders at a bar
now is the time to sort of start
preparing to get ready for this sleep
event you can also by the way just sort
of before sleep in the last hour you can
sort of get into your pajamas your
sleeping clothes brush your teeth flush
your teeth do all of those things that
end up taking away and sort of an
additional 15 minutes or 20 minutes get
those in ahead of time
but what about the snooze button though
unfortunately it's probably not a good
idea because there is some data that i
discuss in the book where if you look at
the cardiovascular response to an alarm
it's actually quite a stressful event
for your cardiovascular system we see a
spike in heart rate stress chemicals
increase
now it's fine to use an alarm just that
one time in the morning to wake you up
but you shouldn't really be hitting the
snooze button because then you are
repeatedly assaulting your
cardiovascular system and you may think
well you know i i only hit it maybe sort
of three or four times you know how bad
is that well maybe for that one day it's
not bad but if you're doing that every
single day every week every month every
year every decade across a lifetime you
can imagine the type of additional
cardiovascular strain that that places
on people so use the alarm that's fine
but try to use it once and then get up
most of you lose control of your life in
the first five minutes after you wake up
i talk about it in my book and you begin
to respond all day long the first thing
is this the hardest thing you will do
and the thing that will change your life
almost with the greatest impact is to
not check your phone for the first 30
minutes you wake up in the morning i'm
telling you that it might be the biggest
game changer it is the biggest game
changer for me it was so difficult
because so what i did is i i moved it
away from where i sleep but i'm just
going to say to you all you think that's
not a big deal i got to check it i'm
telling you if you could go 30 minutes
if you could start by going 10 minutes
to begin your day something where you do
not check that and react and then what
you say about the gratitude thing that's
profound for me and it's a breakthrough
for me when you said it i'm always kind
of like what are the big things i'm
great i'm grateful for god i'm grateful
for my kids you reduce it down to just
something what's the smallest thing you
could be grateful for right i love that
because there's always a small thing you
could be grateful for you know i'm
grateful my i clipped my toenails
yesterday whatever it is right there's
something so i just want to validate how
powerful i think both those simple tools
the simplest things make the biggest
impacts in our lives is there any daily
disciplines that you have in your life
daily routines that you would attribute
to your success
uh
yeah i try to beat the sun up
i write my goals down every day
and i try to get i try to hit the gym
so i don't do it perfect every day sure
um some things throw me off and and um
you know unfortunately i have a i
created a lifestyle where where some
things are taking care for me that that
that um
most people don't have that that option
you know somebody drives the kids to
school i don't have to do that that
would change everything
if i had to do that who knows maybe i
need to maybe i need to start driving
the kids to school it seems like a
complete waste of time to me but
um i live two two minutes from my office
so when i bounce out of here i gotta go
do a live a live stream on real estate
but but uh
yeah that that's the first three things
if i can get that done in the morning
man i know i'm gonna have a good day
yeah pretty simple need to beat the sun
up make sure you write down your goals
yeah make sure you take care of yourself
get the blood flow and get the heart
pumping yeah and i goes down fresh a new
unit like in a new unit of time like
i've written down today like i had never
written them down before
thanks
yeah
that's um so so so simple on the outside
but so many people won't do
those
i dare everybody listening here to try
to do it for 30 days in a row see if you
can even make seven what's your morning
routine
every morning without fail the first
thing i do is i run
without fail i haven't missed a day of
running since 2016. okay so i get up i
do that four days out of the week i go
to the gym and every single night
for five and a half years i stretch out
for at least two hours that was a killer
part of the book every [ __ ] night
that is that's where i so when you go so
hard
mentally physically emotionally
spiritually you have to have time set
aside to quiet
and recover
recovery is big the mind especially the
mind and the body this is my time
there's no phone calls there's no emails
the world does not exist
because i have to get ready for tomorrow
get the body opened up why because as i
won't get you know
you went deeper
it was awesome but your body's getting
tight yeah you go hard tom yeah a lot of
people go hard what happens is that
stress yep it starts to tighten up that
psoas muscle hip flexors
you got so
problems all of a sudden you have no
idea why it's all tightness it's all
tightness man because you're you're
constantly charged and going hard if i
immediately when i wake up i can't check
my phone in fact i put it on airplane
mode and i move it i got that from
ariana huffington who's amazing and
she's like is your phone still by your
bed she goes airplane mode on the other
side of the room you know
um
so that and then
i just know so many people roll over and
grab their phone and to me that's like
russian roulette you put a bullet in the
gun and you spin it it's like what if
the email says the deal didn't happen
numbers are down life's not working out
like
and immediately for me it's like you
open up and and this little box is gonna
dictate the first couple hours or maybe
the whole day by what you see so i just
i just won't look at my phone when i
first wake up
um so but when i first open my eyes this
is all and i like doing things quick for
me because i want to get to the gym
because the only time of day i'll go if
i try to wait till the afternoon it
doesn't work for me so as soon as i wake
up i immediately try to think of
something i'm grateful for which
everybody knows that and thinks about it
but i've i play this game myself on how
far i can lower the bar
meaning
i i try to do a gratitude journal about
three years ago and after about five
weeks i ran out of stuff to say i'm like
i already wrote my kids and this and
life like what did i put in here like
and then i was like wow 150 000 people
die every single day you can google it
that's the number it's like some days i
wake up i'm just like i'm here awesome
and i let i feel that silly little thing
like i'm here or i'll be like oh my god
the sheets feel
softer than they've ever felt and i'll
literally think to myself these sheets
are really good like
what a third of the world sleeps on the
on a dirt floor
and i have sheets and an amazing bed and
look at the view i have and that's
enough just because the way i know is
i'm just just tweaking my brain enough
to be in a grateful place it doesn't
have to be this for me and you guys
might have better practices i'm not
talking about a half hour gratitude
meditation i just need one little thing
or i pick up a book if i'm reading one
of the books that you have on the shelf
i'll pick and i'll just pick three
sentences and read something empowering
and i'll get that state of mind for my
brain and then i think about
one win i had the day before because i
know as entrepreneurs as somebody
searching for success we never give
ourselves credit we never treat a friend
the way we treat ourselves it's like i
know i've had days i've gone till 10
o'clock at night go man i got nothing
done today was the biggest lie like we
beat ourselves up we just were like
these racehorses we wouldn't even treat
a racehorse that we owned as bad as we
treat ourselves right so
i wake up and i'll do a quick little
gratitude and they'll say what was one
win yesterday that i accomplished and
i'm like wow you did do that yesterday
and then i'll think of one win i wanna
do that day like what i'm gonna get a
million things done today but what's a
must today that would be a great win
and then for me then i immediately go
downstairs in my house and i drink i
felt like i fed my my mind and then i
want to feed my body so for me i've been
doing the same drink forever i do apple
cider vinegar lemon
mct oil a scoop of green powder
and
mix that up and i down that and then i
immediately got to go to the gym you
know my morning routine five years ago
was i would get up and i would look at
my emails a couple of them i wouldn't
let them consume me because i'm dyslexic
and i know that when you read it takes
more of the brain to utilize to read it
so i would use it to stimulate my brain
right i'd get up i'd read my goals like
i've always done and um i would uh try
to eat something healthy and then i
would get to the office because i was
like i can't work out too early because
number one there's a lot of fires i need
to put out and i can't do that um as i
started to uh realize what was going on
i started do these interviews with
people i started saying all right may i
need to change this around so now it's
totally different so i'll get up i'll do
my goals i'll still do that small part
of reading the the um email but i will
not look at social media which i used to
and now i'll go work out because i used
to work out at night when i felt that my
emails weren't coming in that much and i
wanted to kind of get tired so i
arrested but
i start working out now early
earlier in the day and and i start also
scheduling time with my daughter and
with my family to make sure that that is
priority over anything else and i also
schedule any kind of health things i
need to do doctors checkups physicals
whatever the case is what that did was
i'm more productive because the
adrenaline running and i got to work and
i'm i'm i'm more active i didn't eat the
egg and cheese sandwich was slowing me
down right and i need to chill out for a
little while i started doing my uh
spending more time with my family and
because i started to say i'm going to
make a major appointment any kind of
appointment i can once a month for my
health i ended up finding out i had
stage two cancer
after reading after sudden uh to find
out all you know all these people's
techniques because i looked further into
my health and i ended up finding out i
had stage two cancer and it didn't save
my life necessarily because i had
thyroid cancer which would still be a
challenge but i had a surgery and i got
the cancer removed i'm cancer-free and
um and it was because of me altering my
life uh with these small adjustments
sleep is huge yeah like sleep is huge
you know a lot of people are like yeah
whatever i'll sleep when i'm dead no no
no no sleep when you're alive and your
life will be much better yes i think 50
cent said uh
sleep is for those who are broke
and i think when i was in my early
entrepreneurial days i used like yeah
sleepers for those who are broke if you
want to like make money and build your
business you got to hustle and do
whatever it takes and then i was just
like wow i'm actually getting fat i'm
exhausted i'm really angry i'm
there is there's a lot of links between
sleep and mental illness bro people who
don't sleep enough can suffer can
develop anxiety disorder and all these
things um so sleep is huge for me and i
like my mornings i like usually my
mornings to be i like the two or three
hours to like drink like some some
coffee philosophy i like to do some so i
like to do some exercise in the morning
just whatever like some push-ups some
pull-ups just kind of some quick get to
get it out of the way um have my
breakfast do email and then usually
after that like around midday by one i
like to switch from from that kind of
caffeinated email workout thing and then
after that i like to switch it and go
into free free association creative mode
and that's like let's go see a film or
let's go for a hike right you know
something that is about disconnection so
the morning is connect focus and then
afternoon is divergent thinking morning
is convergent thinking afternoon is
divergent thinking i think that's a good
balance for me any busy schedule i think
it's just important to stay
grounded and remember that you're a
human being not a machine and it's
really important to wake up in the
morning and take a deep breath and look
around at the people that you love and
realize that that's really the most
important thing and it sounds corny and
cliche until you start to do it every
day and then i've found that my life is
so much more fulfilled because of that
what is your morning routine like what
do you do when you first get up in the
morning you know believe it or not i
still you know i read a physical paper
every single morning which one i read
the wall street journal every morning i
read the new york times online
and you know i still am very particular
about having my tea it's very english
you know i grew up in india
so having my tea and
i'm vegetarian so i need to get my
protein so i always have an omelette in
the morning
with toast
tea
and read my paper so i do that every
morning what time do you wake up uh 6 30
to 7 so that's when i do it do you
exercise in the morning
uh now later in the day sometimes
you know if i get a chance but always in
the evening i wish i could do it in the
morning i'm not a
morning person so i need my time with my
paper and tea to wake up and kind of get
going i've touched on a couple of times
we've done over 300 shows and i've
talked about
being able to handle the wattage of this
abundance that you want to have are you
actually capable of handling that good
that you actually want to have yeah
right
and it it takes a lot of inner work it
takes a lot of physical work you know
it's not just a mental or spiritual
thing but physically to be able to
handle all of that goodness and even i
know it sounds crazy but you could
probably speak on that a little bit too
yeah no no some people
i've worked with a guy named uh master
and dr shaw he's probably one of the
biggest healers in the world you know
grand master from china and he's a
medical doctor he gave me these beads
and i i trace calligraphies for energy
and enlightenment every day to carry
that energy and when people go to his
workshops at the end the biggest comment
i always get is man i feel terrible
right i feel so bad because physically
they can't handle
like literally when you go to tony
robbins or other workshops if you ever
end it and you just think you're
exhausted but you actually physically
ache and people get sick sometimes yeah
it's because they can't physically
handle the elevation that quick you know
it's like not jogging and then running a
marathon right your body's going to be
really sore
it's not humanly impossible but you can
actually do that emotionally energy in
motion and i see it all the time that
people don't uh as john assaraf says
they don't do the appropriate inner size
they do the appropriate exercise
but they're not using the parts of their
inner size to make sure they're fit and
ready for what they're asking for yeah
so what do you recommend people do to do
that exercise absolutely meditate and
every day so one of the things that i
teach is the consistency of things i
believe two minutes of meditation every
day is worth more than an hour a week i
can prove it in sports golf's the
easiest way i'll tell anyone look golf
30 minutes a day with the appropriate
help 30 minutes a day focusing in on a
certain area of the game by an end of
the year you'll be a much better golfer
guarantee even if you don't play one
round of golf
whereas if you play six hours of golf
every week on a saturday which is twice
as much time as a half an hour every day
you could be worse a worse golfer same
thing's true about meditation and that's
because there's exponential power in
doing something every day it goes from
your cellular to your neural pathways
into your unconscious even the genetic
mistakes that are associated with
disease
depends on how you live your life and
very simple things like sleep
meditation and stress management
movement
yoga and pranayama now yoga and pranam
goes way beyond exercise because with
yoga and pranayam there's a particular
nerve in the body called the vagus nerve
it's the tenth nerve
and the word vegas is a latin word but
it's related to the english word
vagabond so this nerve comes from the
midbrain
it influences your facial expressions so
you can now do micro expressions and see
if a person is happy or not it
influences the
eye movements
it influences the tone of your voice are
you threatened are you stressed are you
friendly are you happy
it influences your heart rate activity
then it pierces the diaphragm
and it influences the activity of every
other
branch of the vegas nerve that goes to
all the organs in the body
so when i discovered this through yoga
teachers and masters
i realized that the yoga asanas you know
we say yoga asana
and people usually translate that into
as postures
but actually the word asana means seat
as you know seat of awareness seat of
consciousness so each yogasana is a
particular seat of consciousness
that stimulates a particular nerve that
is going to
organ in your body and the only
reason for that nerve is self-regulation
or healing or homeostasis so when i
discovered that i became fanatic about
yoga i haven't missed yoga
now for as long as i can remember that's
amazing wow not one day of yoga or
meditation
or um or pronouns now building yourself
begins with intention
clarity you have to know who you want to
become
you can't just show up in the gym of the
mind and do random stuff any more than
you can show up in the gym of the body
and do random stuff and think that
you're going to end up on the stage
competing for mr olympia
it doesn't work like that
you've got to have this clarity of focus
and the way that i always explain it to
people people come to me all the time
and they're like tom
i want to help people man
and i'm like that is rad that's coming
from such a beautiful place
but telling me that you want to help
somebody is like saying you want to win
a gold medal
in what
the olympics
yes fantastic summer or winter
summer great tennis are swimming
swimming
which event
backstroke the medley because until you
know exactly in what way you are trying
to serve people you don't know what
skills you need to acquire in order to
leave people in awe so that you may
become extraordinary
skills have utility learning how to swim
better makes you a faster swimmer
building certain muscles in your arms
and in your shoulders
all of the different things that go into
getting great at any sport all of those
things must be learned with calculation
they must be practiced and rehearsed
over and over and over you have to push
yourself long past the point of boredom
boredom kills more people in the pursuit
of success than any hater will ever
boredom is the great killer of dreams
boredom
because people don't have the focus they
don't have the clarity of what they're
trying to achieve they've not built into
their life built into their life an
intoxication for what they're trying to
accomplish
mitochondria their job is to stay alive
and then their job is also to kill off
the weak so you got to stress them
enough to kill off the weak and that
process is is called apoptosis
if you don't do that you get cancer so
you want to you want to stress
you want to stress them but not too much
so it's brief periods of stress
so there's like ice ice is great jobs or
ice showers yeah just a cold shower in
the morning not a whole cold shower
because cold showers suck let's face it
yeah just take a hot shower at the end
turn on cold do it all at once and just
feel the pain for a minute those little
guys they're gonna freak out that makes
them stronger they get stronger and the
weak ones die
right and then you burn more calories
throughout the day your brain is clearer
and inflammation goes down and here's
the interesting thing every time you
have inflammation it's because your
mitochondria aren't working very well so
if something makes you inflamed it's
because you damaged your battery system
in the body when things are working well
they they actually change the structure
of the water in your body it's called
exclusion zone water and no one knew
mitochondria could do this until a
couple years ago gerald pollock figured
this out and he talked about it at the
bulletproof conference
so all of a sudden
you're just telling these little guys
hey the world isn't always warm and soft
and fuzzy maybe you should just toughen
up a little bit
and then that toughness gets built into
your system and you carry it with you
for the rest of the day and so you're a
little leaner you're a little just just
more on point and it cost you nothing in
fact you saved a quarter cent on heating
hot water for that last one like it was
just a change in habit
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know the 10 morning routines for
a perfect day check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i have my vision board and my
goals everything that i want but i also
have a gratitude board the things that
i'm most grateful for in my life and if
you want to feel instant gratitude just
count all the things in your life that
you have that money